CARTER MORGAN: I'm Carter.
And today, I'm going to discuss
intelligent document processing
with AppSheet Automation.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Process automation can
help with manual task.
But some of that manual
work done each day
requires taking data from a
document, like an invoice,
and inputting it
into another data
source or a disparate system.
This takes up valuable
time that could be used
to focus on high-impact work.
AppSheet combines the power of
no-code development with Google
Cloud's state-of-the-art
Document AI to automatically
extract and validate your data--
like invoices,
receipts, et cetera--
making your workflows
more efficient and free
from guesswork, all while
keeping the human in the loop.
You can think of this
intelligent document processing
functionality like a layer.
It sits on top of
the automations
you can build currently,
creating a different way
to trigger automation events
or showcase information
in your applications from
unstructured document data.
Let's explore an example
of how this is done.
Ben works on a finance team for
a large transportation firm.
Each week, he receives
hundreds of pictures
of receipts and PDFs
of invoices that
need to be processed for
reimbursements and payments
to various teams
across the country.
These are time sensitive.
He needs a way to keep up
with the increasing number
of documents sent his way.
He has access to both Google
Workspace and AppSheet,
allowing a fast
path to a solution,
even though he's not a coder.
By creating and connecting
designated folders
in his Google Drive account
to his AppSheet applications,
he'll be able to upload
pictures of receipts
and PDFs of invoices to perform
a designated series of actions.
For reimbursements, he can
trigger both the extraction
of the data and an approval
request notification
to his manager, all by
uploading invoice and receipt
documents to the
preselected Drive folder.
If he really wants to
take it to the next level,
he can refine the
application experience
that houses
automation so that he
can perform this action
from a mobile device
while he's working with
the teams in the field.
These benefits don't just need
to apply to those in finance.
Anyone on your team
can create impact
by removing the time spent
on document processing
with no-code platforms
like AppSheet.
Ready to change how you work?
Get started by
clicking this link.
[MUSIC PLAYING]